[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
you
you
the year is 2048 30 years ago we
outsource the very runnings of our lives
to machines machines that learn the
machines learnt too well today all
computing resource on the planet has
been consolidated in a vast maze hewn
out of solid rock no humans have access
to the maze reactors makes an ideal home
for millions of flesh-eating rats
your mission is the end of the maze
sabotage the power source of the
machines and free the human race from
its self-inflicted automated prison
you are our last best hope but until
today no human has survived
of the rats rats
you
you
human hackers have penetrated the
machines networks and obtained some
basic intelligence on the configuration
of their defenses
before you enter the maze we will
provide a brief overview of what we have
learned so far
the machines hired deep in their maze
from where they control our world
disable their power to free all humans
each maze has a reactor find the reactor
sabotage escape follow markers to reach
your goal we have identified three
primary variants of vermin the breeder
at the baby rent the kilo red superior
machine engineering creates rat breeding
factories
destroy rats have no mercy in a tight
situation you're super Zappa will help
you survive
before you enter the maze we will
provide a brief training simulation
[Music]
[Music]
are you ready you look ready
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the maze exists as a grid
we represent the amazing memory as a
one-dimensional array we can easily
translate between the XY coordinates of
the cells and the grid and the zero
indexed elements of the array that are
these cells each sellers are so
contain simulation implemented as a
function object it has attributes that
describe the cell and arrays to hold the
collections of actors that exist within
the cell one of ourselves attributes are
its neighbors a four element array
representing north east south and west
if a given side of the cell is closed
the corresponding element in the
neighbors array is known if the side of
the cell is open the corresponding
element holds a reference to the
function object that is the neighboring
cell this lets us create a traversable
graph of cells that are connected
together and have cells that are
completely isolated from their neighbors
giving us access to a bountiful
abundance of powerful algorithms to make
a maze we start with a grid of
completely disconnected cells pick a
cell at random any cell will do pick a
neighbor of that cell ensuring that
neighbor has no connections of its own
create a mutual connection between the
two cells push the cell we came from
onto a stack or repeat the process from
the neighboring cell we selected as we
work our way through the grid we build
up a list of places we visited when
there are no more cells to explore we
pop an element off the stack and work
back the way we came
following up any unexplored cells we
find along the way when there's nothing
left on our stack we know we formed our
perfect maze
each cell is a self-contained simulation
it is a floorspace and collections of
actors that interact with each other
within that space a game loop runs 60
times a second
driven by window don't
requestanimationframe each frame we
iterate through our array of cells
giving each one a chance to run its
simulation so it's actors can observe
their environment and react accordingly
the simulations use simple counters
periodic waveforms and the probability
of events occurring to modulate
parameters and trigger effects each
class of actor has a set of interacting
behaviors combining several simple
behaviors together can make for complex
results when an actor moves to the edge
of a cell and that edge is closed
they reflect off the walls exert a kind
of short-range as some topic
anti-gravity expressed as a force vector
and applied to the actors velocity
causing them to move away from the wall
if the side of the cell is open the
actor is moved into the neighboring cell
with a bit of mass applied to their
position to reflect their entry point
the human exhibits a consuming impulse
to seek the reactor sabotage and escape
the rats exhibit a base
flocking behavior with a cluster and
move together as a group or maintaining
some separation from their friends
the killer ants have the same base
behavior but a possessed to seek the
human and devour his flesh both basic
behaviors beholden us be able to find
our way through the mains we always have
an origin and a desired destination
because we have a perfect maze we can
always find away from oneself to any
other from our origin we expand a search
frontier through every connected cell we
can find as we search we record the
place we came from and calculate the
cost in terms of distance for us to get
to each cell if for a given path there
are no more cells to explore we
terminate our search on that path if we
reach our destination our search is
complete and we use a list of places we
came from to determine our route we can
enhance the solver to the cost
calculation for each cell based roughly
on the distance from that cell to our
destination and following the path with
the lowest cost to help us reach our
goal quickly when the human enters the
maze he uses the formula to determine
the route to the reactor the steps of
the path are contained in an array of
cell indexes arranged an order from
start to finish from the seller humanism
we determine the exit that is connected
to the next step in the path and apply a
force vector to the human in that
direction pushing him out through the
exit and into the next cell until he
reaches the reactor when it's time to
escape the path is reversed
it would be too expensive to calculate
the path through the maze for each
individual rent so before updating each
cell determines the route through its
neighbors to the human applying a force
vector to all killer rats on the cell
pushing them out through the exit
creating the illusion that they are
seeking the human to devour his flesh
when a maze is created we need to seed
it with interesting objects some cells
have a special object in them like the
reactor or a rant Factory the first cell
in the maze is always the ingress the
human enters through the last cell is
always the reactor the human follows a
path from the ingress to the reactor and
back we can treat the sips of this path
as linear and pick points of random or
according to some rules placing items in
the cells referenced by those points we
can also place items off the path so
they have an effect on play but don't
interfere with the humans movement a
level counter is incremented each time a
maze is completed as the human
progresses through the levels the mazes
get larger with more devious entities
hiding in their depths the occurrence of
monsters in the first four levels is
hard-coded
but beyond that some cheap tricks are
employed to create the illusion of
forethought if we take a level number
and apply some modular arithmetic we can
activate a disable the occurrence of
certain effects and objects based on the
result every third level zooms to follow
the human every seventh lever has extra
power-ups every thirteenth level is a
tiny maze
the future is uncertain but one day soon
the human race must enter the maze of
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]